ever wondered how modern technology has
revolutionized the way we Harvest crops
let's delve into that today it's a
fascinating time to be involved in
agriculture the industry is experiencing
a technological Renaissance with
Innovative Machinery taking Center Stage
these advancements have not only made
farming more efficient but also
sustainable laying the foundation for a
future where we can feed more people
with less impact on our planet one of
the areas where we've seen a significant
shift is in the harvesting of crops gone
are the days of backbreaking Labor under
the scorching sun today we have
specialized machines designed to harvest
specific crops with precision and speed
let's take a look at three of these
remarkable machines that are shaping the
future of harvesting the pumpkin
Harvester the brussel sprout Harvester
and the Walnut Harvester each of these
machines is a testament to human
Ingenuity a Marvel of engineering that
has revolutionized how we gather our
crops the pumpkin Harvester for instance
is a giant leap forward from the
traditional methods of harvesting it's
designed to pick trim and load pumpkins
with minimal human intervention ensuring
a quick and efficient Harvest next up is
the Brussels sprout Harvester this
Innovative machine makes the once
laborious task of picking Sprouts a
breeze speeding up the process and
allowing Farmers to harvest more in less
time and let's not forget the Walnut
Harvester this machine has turned what
was once a timeconsuming and labor
intensive process into a Swift and
straightforward task ensuring that we
can enjoy our favorite nutty treats all
year round as you can see technology has
truly transformed the way we Farm but
how exactly do these machines work the
pumpkin Harvester a Marvel of modern
technology but what makes it so unique
the pumpkin Harvester is an impressive
Fusion of engineering and agriculture at
the heart of its design it is a desire
for efficiency and precision a machine
built to answer the demands of a Time
crunched world let's delve into what
makes this machine tick first and
foremost the pumpkin Harvester uses an
advanced picking system it doesn't just
indiscriminately pluck every pumpkin in
its path no this machine is smarter than
that it uses sensors to detect ripe
pumpkins ensuring that only those ready
for Harvest are picked it's a perfect
blend of sensitivity and strength able
to handle the delicate task of picking
without damaging the fruit but the
pumpkin Harvester doesn't stop there
once the ripe pumpkins are picked
they're sorted this is where the
machine's efficiency really shines it
uses a conveyor system to transport the
pumpkins sorting them by size as they
move along this means that by the time
the pumpkins reach the end of the line
they're already organized and ready for
Market the Brilliance of the pumpkin
Harvester lies in its ability to
streamline the harvesting process it
eliminates Ates the need for manual
labor saving precious time and effort
this isn't just a machine it's a
solution a way to tackle the challenges
of modern farming headon and of course
it's not just about efficiency the
pumpkin Harvester is also about
sustainability it's designed to minimize
waste and maximize yield this is a
machine that respects the Earth it works
on a tool that understands the balance
between progress and preservation the
pumpkin Harvester is a testament to how
far we've come but it's not the only
machine Making Waves in the farming
industry the future of harvesting
promises even more innovative solutions
machines that continue to push the
boundaries of what's possible in
agriculture the pumpkin Harvester is
just the beginning meet the Brussels
sprout Harvester a machine that has
revolutionized the way we Harvest these
small green gems this Marvel of modern
agriculture technology is a GameChanger
in the world of brussel sprout farming
so how does it work well the brussel
sprout Harvester is built with Precision
technology it's designed to navigate
through rows of Brussels sprouts with
ease making the process of harvesting
these delicate vegetables much swifter
and more efficient as it moves along the
machine gently shakes the stalks causing
the Sprouts to fall below a conveyor
belt catches these falling Sprouts
ensuring none are lost or damaged it's a
fascinating site A Perfect Blend of
human Ingenuity and Technology but it
doesn't stop there once the Sprouts are
collected the machine then sorts them
yes you heard that right the Brussels
sprout Harvester not only picks the
Sprouts but also sorts them using
Advanced sensors and sorting algorithms
it separates the Sprouts based on their
size and quality the result a batch of
perfectly sorted and undamaged brussel
sprouts ready for packaging and delivery
now what sets the brussel sprout
Harvester apart is its focus on
minimizing damage brussel sprouts are
known for their delicate nature
traditional methods of harvesting can
often lead to a significant amount of
the crop being damaged or lost but with
this machine each Sprout is handled with
the utmost care ensuring a higher yield
and better quality produce and let's not
forget about the time saved what would
typically take several hours if not days
can now be accomplished in a fraction of
the time this means farmers can Harvest
their crop at the optimal time ensuring
the freshest most delicious Sprouts make
it to your dinner table impressive isn't
it but with not done yet there's one
more machine you need to know about the
Walnut Harvester a machine that has
changed the game for Walnut Farmers
imagine a machine that simplifies a
complex task making it efficient and
effortless that's exactly what the
Walnut Harvester does this ingenious
piece of Machinery is transforming the
way walnuts are harvested ensuring high
quality yield while reducing the labor
intensity typically associated with the
process so how does the Walnut Harvester
work well it's quite fascinating the
machine uses advanced technology to
maneuver through Walnut Orchards with
precision as it passes over the trees it
gently shakes them causing the ripe
walnuts to fall onto a conveyor system
the walnuts are then transported to a
sorting area within the machine here
they are meticulously inspected and
sorted based on their size and quality
but that's not all the Walnut Harvester
is also equipped with Innovative
features that enable it to perform its
tasks with utmost efficiency for
instance it has a state-of-the-art
sensor system that detects the presence
of walnuts ensuring that none are left
behind additionally it uses high-speed
cameras to inspect each Walnut
discarding those that do not meet the
quality standards The Machine's
efficiency doesn't stop at picking and
sorting walnuts it's also designed to
minimize damage to the walnut trees
during the harvesting process the Walnut
Harvester's gentle shaking mechanism
ensures that the trees are not harmed
preserving their health for future
harvests the Walnut Harvester is a
testament to how far we've come in
agricultural technology it's a machine
that not only improves the quality and
quantity of the yield but also makes the
process more sustainable with such
machines on their side Walnut farmers
can look forward to more productive and
profitable seasons in essence the Walnut
Harvester is a GameChanger it's a
machine that hints at the exciting
possibilities of what the future of
farming could look like these machines
are truly the future of farming but what
does this mean for us so what does the
Advent of these modern harvesting
machines mean for us and for the future
of farming well let's delve into this
fascinating topic modern harvesting
machines have brought about a revolution
in agriculture and their impact cannot
be overstated one of the most
significant benefits is the incredible
increase in
efficiency these machines can do in
hours what would take days or even weeks
for human labor to accomplish they can
work tirelessly Round the Clock and in
all weather conditions this efficiency
translates into a significant increase
in crop yield which is crucial in a
world where the demand for food is
constantly on the rise reduced labor is
another major advantage farming is a
labor intensive profession and these
machines can significantly lessen the
physical strain on Farmers they can do
the heavy lifting quite literally this
not only makes the process more
manageable but also frees up the farmers
to focus on other aspects of their
business now let's consider the
potential impact on the farming industry
with these machines Farms can become
more self-sufficient and less reliant on
external labor this can lead to a shift
in the industry's dynamic with Farms
becoming more centralized and efficient
it's also worth considering the
potential for job creation in areas such
as machine maintenance and operation and
let's not forget the exciting
possibilities for future technological
advancements we're already seeing
machines that can sort and pack produce
and who knows what the future holds
perhaps we'll see machines that can
plant and nurture crops or even machines
that can predict the best time to
harvest based on weather patterns and
crop Health as we can see the future of
farming is here and it's more efficient
than ever technology has and will
continue to revolutionize the way we
Farm stay tuned for more insights into
the world of modern
agriculture